le grand prix de vélizy fêté ce dimanche
sa troisième édition lancée en 2014
l'événement organisé par l'équipe
cycliste vélizy 78 est intégré à la
coupe d'île de france
au programme de l'omnium du keirin du
scratch de la vitesse et les courses
points notre vocation bien sûr c'est de
permettre aux coureurs régionaux de
s'exprimer sur ce magnifique vélodrome
la vocation donc c'est de permettre à
des jeunes de découvrir cette magnifique
piste et pourquoi pas de découvrir le
champion de demain
cette année 125 fois revenue de 10
régions se sont inscrits pour participer
à l'événement j'avoue faire plaisir et
qu'on a la chance d'avoir
vous pouvez le drôme de france à saint
quentin donc quand il ya des courses on
vient on en profite même si je suis pas
au mieux de ma forme
ça fait plaisir de courir c'est juste
exceptionnel de venir sera surtout le
drame national pourquoi recourir comme
le professionnel georges un plateau qui
a séduit le public ils étaient plus de
500 spectateurs dans les tribunes pour
assister à l'événement je trouve ça
convivial et très intéressant
vous être qui sait mais c'est un peu la
vocation de ce genre d'épreuve c'est de
faire venir du public public sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
pour justement fidéliser après vélizy le
vélo club de montigny le bretonneux
organisera la seconde manche de la coupe
de france le 11 décembre prochain
toujours au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines